[Applaudissements]
bonjour alors j'ai rencontré
l'intelligence artificielle je devais
avoir 12 13 ans je crois et au détour
d'une encyclopédie
je suis tombé sur cet objet magnifique
en cuivre laiton et j'ai compris alors
il s'agit de calculateurs arithmétique
de pascal autrement nommée la pascaline
et de jeunes blaise pascal vers 19 20
ans 740 l'idée de réaliser une machine à
faire des opérations arithmétiques des
additions et des soustractions mêmes
démultiplication et j'étais vraiment
fasciné par le fonctionnement de cette
machine et en particulier par l'idée
vous savez quand vous êtes une addition
vous additionnez 999 +1 et vous avez une
retenue qui doit se déplacer du début
jusqu'à la fin pour arriver à 1000 et
donc je voyais comment à l'intérieur de
cette machine ses engrenages permettait
à cette retenue de se propager de
d'engrenages en au grenache pour arriver
au plus vos chiffres et ça c'était pour
moi la première manifestation du fait
que quelques mécaniques pouvait faire
une opération mental qui était très
important parce qu'on avait appris à
calculer à l'école et du coup j'ai
compris où il me semblait qu'il y avait
pas de limites à cette idée qu'ont pu
réaliser une intelligence artificielle à
partir de mécanique
ma mère était au biologiste donc au même
moment elle corriger des copies d'élèves
l'arrivée des dessins de parent mais si
elle mettait des héros sur 20 parce
qu'ils savaient pas dessiner et là
c'était une copie plus anciennes
d'ailleurs d'un livre d'un biologiste
espagnol savall ramon caral qui est le
premier audit mais à la fin du 19e
siècle début du 20ème siècle s'est rendu
compte que le cerveau c'était pas de la
cervelle c'était pas une masse
blanchâtre non à l'intérieur du cerveau
qu'un microscope on voyait des neurones
maintenant tout le monde connaît les
neurones et on voit très très
distinctement dans ce diagramme le fait
que le neurone prend ses informations
par des centaines ou des milliers de
connexions dans les dendrites amène
cette information sur le coeur
qui donc le corps cellulaire du neurone
et ensuite prend une décision et envoie
d'autres informations à travers son axe
zone pour
lui-même activé avec un influx nerveux
d'autres neurones d'ailleurs ravi qu'atr
l'a bien vu que c'était pas un fil
électrique un neurone l'information va
dans un sens il ya des petites flèches
sur le diagramme il a donc compris le
fonctionnement du neurone voilà les deux
acteurs de cette discussion
l'intelligence artificielle à votre
gauche
le lointain descendant de cette machine
de pascal qui est le dernier
microprocesseurs bête de course de
l'entreprise intel 7 milliards de
transistors dans quelque chose qui est
plus grand que cet espace autant de
transistors que d'êtres humains sur
terre 1 milliards d'opérations par
seconde alors qu'avec la machine de
pascal on faisait une opération tous les
30 à 40 secondes et puis à votre droite
là c'est la photographie d'un morceau de
cortex d'une souris la souris arc en
ciel qui était un peu modifié pour qu'on
puisse voir distinctement de des
couleurs différentes
chacun des neurones qui le composent
notre cerveau à nous c'est 100 milliards
de neurones reliés par en moyenne dix
mille synapses à d'autres neurones
ça c'est l'intelligence biologique alors
aujourd'hui depuis disons les années
1950 1960 on a progressivement essayer
de réaliser en électronique du logiciel
avec des ordinateurs la même chose que
ce que faisait tout ce que fait notre
neurones et sa part de l'idée qu'on peut
représenter mathématiquement le
fonctionnement des neurones alors pour
faire très très simple c'est un peu la
formule mathématique que vous trouvez là
je vais vous rassurer le neurone prend
toutes ses entrées ces dix mille entrées
chacune d'entre elles et modifier
positivement amplifier ou atténué en
fonction de l'apprentissage c'est votre
apprentissage qui va dans votre vie peu
à peu modifier vos poids synaptique
comme on dit et faire en sorte que ces
informations venant des autres neurones
sont additionnés dans le coeur du
neurone et puis si ça dépasse un certain
seuil
alors le neurone envoie un influx
nerveux vers une autre
notre neurones ouvert des milliers
d'autres neurones et bien on fait à peu
près la même chose dans nos ordinateurs
maintenant on empile des couches de
neurones ça s'appelle le diplôme ning où
les réseaux neuronaux et on a découvert
comment modifier progressivement les
poids de ces réseaux neuronaux
implémenter un logiciel de façon à ce
qu'ils soient capables d'apprendre
nouvelles tâches
c'est comme ça que ça marche dans notre
cerveau je vois une image
je réfléchis et je décide d'agir en
appuyant sur le bouton et est un exemple
de tâches parmi d'autres c'est la
reconnaissance d'objets dans une image
alors ça c'est une base de données qui
contient 14 millions d'image vous les
verrez pas tout rassurez vous si l'on
est encore là ce soir et il y a fallu
que des gens vous et moi des êtres
humains on a not ses 14 millions d'image
avec plus de 80000 concept art dedans il
ya des chats des chiens des chevaux dès
que vous recherche des camions tout ce
que vous pouvez imaginer tout ça a été à
noter à la main et donc depuis trente à
quarante ans on essaie d'améliorer la
capacité d'un ordinateur reconnaître un
chat d'un chien par exemple dans une
image en hausse en 2011
il y avait 25 % d'erreurs et chaque
année ça progressait de 0 2 0 3 %
2012 est arrivée une équipe de toronto
avec du dip learning des réseaux
neuronaux automatique en divisé par deux
on est arrivé à 12 % de taux d'erreur
l'année d'après google avec beaucoup de
moyens et beaucoup plus de neurones
artificiels arrive et réaliste 6 %
d'erreurs aujourd'hui sur cette tâche là
la machine est plus performante que
chacun d'entre nous elle reconnaît des
idées objets dans des images même quand
les conditions d'éclairage sont
mauvaises même quand il ya très peu de
pixels trèfle août et vous ne
reconnaissez pas la personne la machine
là reconnaît sur une tâche spécialisés
la machine est meilleur que nous une
vision plus poétique on a là trois
réseaux neurones qui ont collaboré celui
qui reconnaît l'image celui qui
synthétise le texte est celui qui en
plus a appris à écrire de manière
manuscrite
tous ensemble ils auraient faire ce que
ma grand mère savait faire mettre une
légende sur une carte postale un grand
pont enjambant la largeur d'une rivière
alors les réseaux de ronde ils font
aussi des erreurs
là c'est un exemple assez amusant vous
reconnaissez tous à gauche un insecte et
une mante religieuse
à droite un chien je savais pas ce que
c'était j'ai fait des recherches
vous savez c'est un bichon frisé
j'espère que quelqu'un le savez est bien
en modifiant un tout petit peu ces
images de manière imperceptible pour
vous c'est un insecte est un chien est
bien le réseau de neurones très
entraînés qui fait aucune erreur il va
en faire une dans les deux cas il va
trouver que c'est une autruche
ça prouve d'ailleurs que ce qui est
écrit dans la bible est vrai puisque
dans la bible vous trouverez dans le
livre de job
dieu a privé l'autruche d'intelligence
donc réseaux de neurones aujourd'hui
nous prouve ce que j'ai écrit dans la
bible
alors c'est ça c'était de l'ia faible
ceni a une intelligence artificielle
spécialisée aujourd'hui pour n'importe
quelle tâche spécialisé si vous avez des
données d'apprentissage et que vous
payez suffisamment de scientifiques pour
organiser le réseau neurones et faire
l'apprentissage
alors on peut faire aussi bien ou même
mieux que le spécialiste humain de cette
tâche par exemple reconnaître une
cellule cancéreuse dans un hymne à une
image du médical ou bien piloter un
réseau télécom mieux que nous mêmes nous
sommes capables de le faire
par contre il faut pas se méprendre sur
la capacité réelle de ces algorithmes
ils sont certes très puissant lanterne
de complexité algorithmique
c'est à peu près au même niveau que
entre pardon l'intelligence de la fourmi
et l'intelligence de la grenouille c'est
ça qu'on a dans les meilleurs réseaux de
neurones aujourd'hui la question d'après
c'est celle de l'ia forte c'est-à-dire
une ya aussi puissante voire même plus
puissante que nous mêmes il ya des tas
de gens qui font l'état de prédictions
celui là monsieur kurt weil qui est un
prospectiviste vaguement transhumanistes
même complètement transhumanisme sur les
bords qui en 2010 disait en 2040 vous
aurez des ya des millions de fois plus
performante qu'un esprit humain
je ne crois pas un instant que cela se
réalisera en fait ce qu'il appelle la
singularité c'est à dire unia qui est
plus intelligente qu'un être humain et
qui en plus est capable de samurais
rapidement elle même et donc de manière
exponentielle nous exploser tous et bien
on fait des petits calculs je vous passe
le graphique ça c'est le progrès de
l'électronique en orange tous les ans
les ordinateurs s'améliore voilà on
s'est projeté depuis des années le
progrès de l'électronique
mais il se trouve que notre cerveau et
progresse en fait ce qu'il progresse
c'est l'estimation que font les
scientifiques de la capacité du cerveau
et si vous regardez la littérature
scientifique
vous voyez que tous les ans des
nouvelles littérature vous disent que le
cerveau il est plus puissant que ce
qu'on croyait
il sait plus d'opérations que ce qu'on
croyait en fait ça progresse aussi vite
que l'électronique donc finalement ça a
peut-être jamais se rencontrer
plus sérieusement je pense que
l'intelligence artificielle fortes en
termes de capacité brute forte de calcul
c'est dans longtemps plus loin de 2050
et peut-être même au-delà
en fait c'est pas le véritable sujet qui
m'intéresse levet est un sujet c'est de
comprendre ce qu'est vraiment
l'intelligence j'aime bien cette
définition
l'intelligence c'est la manière de
parvenir à des buts dans le monde grâce
à des calculs alors je passe sur les
calculs à avec des rouages avec de
l'électronique ou avec du bio logique ce
sont des calculs mais ce qui est
important c'est dans le monde et il ya
plein de monde différent notre monde
dans cette salle le monde mais un
microbe ou le monde d'une bactérie au
fond de l'eau fin fond d'une source
hydrothermale ce ne sont pas les mêmes
monde et donc les buts cette fois les
mêmes et donc les intelligences sont
variés l'intelligence c'est pas du tout
ce qui est sûr ce schéma ce n'est pas
l'idée que on est des êtres les plus
intelligents parce que on a évolué de
manière linéaire à partir du singe et
puis de plein d'autres choses avant non
l'intelligence humaine
elle est extrêmement variée nous sommes
capables de percevoir évidemment
reconnaître des formes dans une image
reconnaître des chaises et des personnes
nous sommes capables de raisonner de
décider ce qui est beaucoup plus dur
surtout décidé me semble-t-il c'est
d'agir
c'était encore plus dur parce qu'on agit
dans des mondes complexe c'est
d'interagir et donc de bénéficier
d'intelligence des autres et de faire
partager la nôtre et surtout c'est
d'avoir des connaissances qui sont
extrêmement variés connaissance d'un
plombier celle d'un physicien nucléaire
ça n'a rien à voir
et il vaut mieux être plombier quand on
n 9 une panne en ailleurs une panne
d'eau donc ses connaissances ses monde
varié et des compétences humaines
cognitives y en a des dizaines
émotionnel non émotionnel je vais pas
entrer dans les détails il a des ailes
l'intelligence artificielle
d'aujourd'hui elle essaye de faire et
elle fait mieux que nous dans certains
domaines très précis et pas du tout dans
tous les autres mais en fait nous êtres
humains nous sommes rien dans cette
création
ça c'est un petit zoom sur la roue
de toutes les organismes qui vit sur
terre toutes les espèces qui vivent sur
terre on est tout petit homo sapiens au
milieu d'une roue qui en fait contient
des espèces allant des protozoaires aux
plantes en passant par les champignons
et les oiseaux en fait il y a deux
millions de formes de vie
chacune des deux formes d'intelligence
parce que la vie elle calcule nous
ribosome c'est un ordinateur
microscopique chimiques qui calcule en
permanence la fourmi qui se déplace en
lâchant des phéromones pour guider les
autres fourmis sur le chemin de la
nourriture c'est une forme
d'intelligence individuelles et
collectives
les bactéries qui échangent des
transmetteurs chimiques
r voilà une forme d'intelligence très
spécialisés s'agit d'un cas snow
américain est en fait il a comme
spécialité juste avant pendant la fin de
l'été de cash et environ 10000 graines
de pin pour faire ses petites réserves
pour l'hiver
il l'aimait par paquet de 5 ou 10 donc
ils environ un millier de cash dans la
forêt sous un arbre sous une feuille
d'une fois dans la terre est bien à la
fin de l'hiver il va les retrouver ses
mille cache dans une forêt avec sa
petite cervelle d'oiseau arrive avant
que vous soyez capable de le faire
aucune ni à ceux entraînés par google
pour faire la même chose on prendra un
petit peu de temps il ya que lui qui
sait le faire et je pense pour un
certain temps une autre forme
d'intelligence beaucoup plus
microscopique c'est celle qui va animer
ces deux espèces différentes
une espèce de champignon en bleu à peu
près 10 micromètres
et puis des bactéries en gris sur cette
image est en fait ces deux espèces elles
parlent entre elles une langue la langue
est d'ailleurs la plus parlée sur terre
ce n'est pas l'anglais ça n'est pas le
français est la langue c'est le terreau
peine terpènes c'est une molécule
chimique qui s'échangent entre ces deux
espèces et des entre bien d'autres
espèces et qui fait qu'une espèce réagi
au comportement de l'autre donc il ya
communication donc il y à intelligence
un dernier exemple ça c'est dans
l'espèce d'une forêt et vous savez que
les arbres communiquer entre eux avec là
encore des molécules chimiques pour
s'avertir des prédateurs qui sont
arrivés et se préparer en réagissant
chacun d'entre eux mais mieux que ça
depuis quelques années on a des
scientifiques ont démontré que leurs
racines étaient reliées entre elles et
quand elle ne l'était pas sont reliés
par des filaments demi ces lieux
de champignons capable non seulement de
transporter des nutriments d'un arbre à
un arbre mais aussi transporter des
informations sous forme électronique ou
chimique est donc là encore d'alerté de
transmettre est de créer avec ce que les
scientifiques ont rappelé le good wife
du web c'est le world wide web des
arbres un réseau très complexe dans
chaque forêt du monde
en tout cas dans les forêts naturelles
beaucoup moins dans les forêts plantées
par l'homme
donc cet écosystème vivant fonctionne de
loin comme notre cerveau des milliers
d'organismes interagissant avec des
décisions des communications le tout
coexistant donc mon message aujourd'hui
c'est que la biosphère notre biosphère
elle est constituée d'intelligent à
toutes les échelles la nôtre avec nos
grands cerveaux extrêmement capables
mais aussi celle des arbres des
bactéries et cette biosphère si on en
regarde la complexité en termes de
puissance de calcul de capacité à
calculer ayant fait quelques
comparaisons et bien entre la plus
grande plus que je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure et notre cerveau humain il faut
multiplier par au moins dix millions la
puissance de calcul pour arriver à 7
cette équivalence et puis si on est 10
milliards d'êtres humains mais on peut
imaginer que tous les êtres mais
ensemble on est 10 millions de fois plus
intelligent qu'un seul être humain
parfois on peut se demander mais si on
regarde la capacité totale de toutes les
espèces qui peuvent le peuplent la terre
et de tous les organismes qui pleuvent
peuplent la terre
en fait il ya plus d'intelligence dans
les bactéries au total passe y en a
beaucoup qu'il n'y en a dans la somme
des êtres humains et donc les 10
puissance 22 organismes qui sont sur
terre les organismes vivants et bien ils
calculent ensemble ils ont ces
interactions ils sont intelligents dans
des mondes très différents des mondes
qui sont pour le coup relativement
inaccessible pour le moment à
l'intelligence artificielle donc mon
point aujourd'hui ce que voudrait que
vous gardiez avec vous pour repartir
c'est pas tant l'idée que peut-être un
jour une ia comme dans celle
de 10 cd ce pas cela qui va décider de
prendre le pouvoir et nous éliminer tous
c'est le fait que cette ia dites fortes
même si elles existaient et ce serait
dans très longtemps
elles seraient cantonnés dans des niches
de spécialités qui sont seuls qu'un
ordinateur peut avoir le fait que nous
ayons des sens le fait que nous ayons un
écosystème le fait que nous vivions au
tour avec une biosphère qui nous entoure
et les cette biosphère étant peu vent
pouvant être analysé comme une vaste
intelligence en tout cas un écosystème
d'intelligence et bien elle va co évolué
avec des ia qui certes vont devenir de
plus en plus puissantes
en termes de puissance de calcul certes
on capable d'attaquer des tâches de plus
en plus sophistiqués peut-être même un
jour d'avoir certaines formes de
créativité si vous avez vu le logiciel
10 pts rim
vous vous dites pas tiens un google ou
en tout cas le lia a pris du lsd donc ça
nous rappelle des choses et donc on a
cette coexistence coexistence entre
forme d'intelligence à des échelles et à
des degrés de compétences très
diversifiée dans un monde très
diversifié et ça c'est fascinant à
observer
il n'y a pas de raison particulière dans
la voix peur comme toute technologie
bien il ya des choses qui vont se passer
en bien en mal la vraie peur dont on
voit avoir c'est celle qu'on doit avoir
de nous mêmes la manière dont nous
gérons ce monde est vraiment ce que je
voudrais vous gardiez avec vous c'est
que cette intelligence artificielle
tant qu'elle reste dans des ordinateurs
tant qu'elle n'est pas ancré dans une
réalité dans des sens dans des émotions
dans la chimie dans la physique il lui
manquera une grande partie de
l'intelligence de notre monde
elle ne saura pas ce qui se passe au fin
fond des océans et au fin fond entre les
racines des arbres et que ce qui est
vraiment important c'est la coexistence
lac aux évolutions de cette intelligence
artificielle qui va évoluer et qui va
s'améliorer et de notre biosphère dans
lequel nous vivons
merci
[Applaudissements]